all right well look uh new single coming
out the 17th
Michael Jordan's birthday easy that's
Michael Jordan's birthday I guess I'm
the goat then it's a big deal yeah
very strange that I know that but shout
out to your NJ fan all right I mean he's
up there with Kobe even though I do
think that he's the actual goat that's
what I have a LeBron James toy
I'm a grown man with toys nah I got some
just a little anime toys at home oh you
are you in the anime I am nice what's
your like like what's your if you had to
you know what are you watching on the
old what's that [__] called Crunchyroll
the [__] anime thing where what's
your animes I'll be watching on Hulu but
I like Attack on Titan okay if no
assassination classroom oh you're you're
tapped in yeah my son says Attack on
Titan I think he says is the best it is
it's a really dope storyline you don't
do the Naruto or the uh yeah
Dragon Ball yeah yeah the first I ain't
got like the first Dragon buys kind of
it's kind of weird [__] you want to know
which anime I've seen The Boondocks oh
yeah that's anime and this is funny and
there is a did some [__] called Afro
Samurai I watched that this year too
those are the only ones I've watched
yeah I like those
is there any other animes that's about
it Boondocks is anime they try to not
count it as one because they're racist
but yeah it's definitely anime yeah
shout out to uh what about Pokemon
yeah when I was younger I liked it you
ever get Pokemon cards yeah I did I was
whooping the existing Pokemon Andy
Yu-Gi-Oh cards Yu-Gi-Oh yeah [__] hey
man I feel like such a nurse by the way
that's okay yeah it's okay to be a nerd
listen we gotta let the people know yeah
a lot of people like anime I'm not one
of them I like the wire you know you
ever watch The Wire
part of y'all never watched it I watched
it like once every two years it was a
long like HBO or something it is okay
it's about Baltimore and heroin and
there's this guy named Omar little he's
gay he but he's like the craziest
[__] alive he'd be robbing all
the drug dealers and [__] little
Puerto Rican dudes in the ass oh my God
he's [__] crazy it's true though
based on the truth for you no no no but
it's it's pretty cool
oh no it is it is actually a lot of it
is like yeah because the guy who wrote
it is from Baltimore so he kind of
wanted to tell you should watch it yeah
outside of anime what's your favorite TV
series
um
the office I love the office the office
is a very good show to fall asleep to it
is you just throw that [__] on it hit
the hit the sheets and you got Steve
Carell in the background I love the
theme song it's a great theme song you
ever watched uh Curb Your Enthusiasm you
got to watch that HBO just get HBO Max
[__] account turn up curb in The Wire
all right all right well listen new
single coming what's the name of the
song Rockstar rockstar I like that
did you ever hear Rock Star by
Nickelback when you were working at
Hollister no I did
no you did you had
time but I don't remember
I just love the Hollister thing
it's great
it's amazing did you get like do you
still have any of the jeans
no no you know what I got like I still
got some of the sweatpants and stuff
[__] right I introduced all the holy
jeans when I was a kid it was like why
is all these [__] rich white kids
wearing jeans with holes in them what
does these were high as [__] I could
barely afford those jeans they were too
much yeah yeah yeah well [__] Hollister
appreciate you pulling up thank you yeah
we're gonna have a freestyle another
YouTube video go watch that [__]